हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग एक बार आप लोग यह
बता दीजिए कंफर्म कर दीजिए की आप सबको
मेरी आवाज ए रही है नहीं ए रही जल्दी से
चाट में बता दिया उसके बाद आगे बातें करते
हैं
ओके थैंक यू
वेलकम तू डिप्रॉनिक्स युटुब चैनल
और सबसे पहले मैं अपने बड़े में बातें
करता हूं
डिप्रॉनिक्स साइबर सिक्योरिटी प्राइवेट
लिमिटेड कंपनी
कोर्स जो काफी हेल्पफुल
प्रोग्राम में
हर प्रोग्राम
बेस्ट कैपिंग और इसके लिए जरूरी है की
आपको प्ले नेक्स्ट की बेसिक नॉलेज हनी
चाहिए तो वह भी आपको पता है की कहां पर
मिल शक्ति है क्योंकि ऑलरेडी एक कोर्स
डिलीवर कर चुके हैं 15 डेज का कैप्सूल
कोर्स जो की आपको यही पर प्ले लिस्ट के
अंदर जाकर मिल जाएगा तो अगर किसी ने अभी
तक लेने है किसी के भी पास वो क्या कर
सकता है वहां पर जाके
उसे नॉलेज को अगेन कर सकता है
15 आप उनको जाकर
वन बाय वन देखिए और वहां से आप अपना
फंडामेंटल क्लियर कर सकते हैं
जब तक आपको उसकी बेसिक नॉलेज नहीं है तब
तक आपको
उसे करना ही होगा
तो एक बार दोबारा
तो कोश में आगे बढ़ाने से पहले एक छोटी सी
इंपॉर्टेंट बात पर डिस्कस करते हैं
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज पर सबसे पहले तो आपका
थैंक यू की इतना सपोर्ट करने के लिए
हमारे अकादमी को और दूसरा वो क्या होता है
किसी भी ट्रेन को काफी मोटिवेट करता है और
हम आपसे बस आप लोगों से हमें कुछ नहीं
चाहिए ना ही हमें पैसे चाहिए ना ही कुछ
चाहिए जस्ट ओनली यू लाइक कमेंट से ही
चाहिए होती है और शेर करते रहिए करते रहिए
बस हमें आप लोगों से यही चाहिए
इस तरीके से बनाया गया डिलीवरी करने के
लिए इसमें प्रोजेक्ट भी रहेंगे आपके और
बहुत साड़ी चीज रहेगी और बीच-बीच में
[संगीत]
पर रिक्वेस्ट है कंडीशन है की नेक्स्ट
वीडियो तभी शेड्यूल होगी आपकी नेक्स्ट
क्लास तभी शेड्यूल होगी चैनल पर जब मेरी
इस फर्स्ट वीडियो पर वन के व्यू होगा बस
एक छोटी सी रिक्वेस्ट है मैं आप लोगों से
पैसे नहीं मांग रहा है
व्यू कैसे आएंगे
वह व्यू आएंगे आपके
शेर करने से तो आप लोग जल्दी से जैसे
क्लास लाइव खत्म हो जाति है जैसे कंप्लीट
करते हो क्लास को तो आप जल्दी से जल्दी
इसको शेर कीजिए और हमारा बैंक व्यू क्रिएट
करवाइए
इस वीडियो पर तो उसके बाद आपको क्या करें
की काफी लॉन्ग वीडियो होती है वन हवास जो
एक घंटा वो काफी ज्यादा हो जाता है
तो अब की बार हम कोशिश करेंगे की
अब की बार आपके जो लेंथ है वीडियो की वो
एक घंटा ना हो बस जो कंटेंट है कंटेंट
डिलीवरी करेंगे डाउट होंगे तो हम ग्रुप
में लेंगे एडरवाइज कुछ
डाउट होगा अभी हम सॉल्व कर देंगे 52 2
मिनट मिनट में हम क्या करें अपने डॉल को
शुरू कर देंगे एडरवाइज जो कंटेंट ये जो
लेंथ रहेगी ये जो क्लास की लेंथ है
नेक्स्ट मैंने अभी सोचिए अबकी बार आप
लोगों के लिए उसका ड्यूरेशन मैंने काम कर
दिया 35 तू 45 मिनट रखेंगे उसमें टॉपिक
लेंगे टॉपिक को अच्छे से क्लियर करेंगे और
उसके बाद हम फरदर सेशन को एड करेंगे और
नेक्स्ट क्लास में उसे टॉपिक को पढ़ेंगे
नेक्स्ट टॉपिक के साथ ओके तो वही है
तो आप लोग बताइए एक बार
[संगीत]
जल्दी से बताइए
ओके सॉरी पर डिस्टरबेंस चलो हम कंटिन्यू
करते हैं तो जो आज का टॉपिक है बिल्कुल
बेसिक से स्टार्ट करेंगे की बेस्ट क्या
होता है सब कुछ क्या होता है हर चीज के
बड़े में डिस्कस करने वाले हैं डोंट वारी
तो क्लास के टाइमिंग रहेंगे 40 या 35 तू
45 मिनट्स तक ही रहेगा वही हम क्लास के
टाइमिंग रखेंगेi कॉन्सेप्ट डिटेल आप
ऑलरेडी जानते हो की ऑलरेडी पढ़ चुके हो की
मैं कॉन्सेप्ट का किस दीप के साथ आप
डिलीवरी करता हूं नो स्टार्ट करते हैं फिर
क्लास को हम आ ये मेरा बोर्ड हमें उसे
करने वाला हूं आज आप लोगों के लिए
तो सबसे पहले
हम बात करते हैं की सेल क्या होता है सबसे
पहले जो मेरा सबसे पहले
है सेल क्या होता है ठीक है सबसे पहले जो
क्वेश्चन
व्हाट इसे ए सेल
क्या होता है
कमांड्स को इंटरप्रेट करता है
की अपने मशीन को इंस्ट्रक्शन पास करते हैं
इसके द्वारा चाइल्ड के द्वारा
जो कमांड है उसको क्या करता है इंटरप्रेट
करता है और इंटरप्रेट करके क्या करता है
आपके ओपनिंग सिस्टम को बोलते हैं की भैया
जो यूजर्स है वो आपसे ये टास्क करवाना
चाहता है तो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम क्या करता है
उसके अकॉर्डिंग उसकी जो परमीशंस के
अकॉर्डिंग या दास के सिक्योरिटी को देखते
हुए उसके टास्क परफॉर्म करता है
अगर मैं सेल के बड़े में लिखूं तो सेल
क्या है डेफिनेशन इसकी क्या है मैं आपके
बड़े में अभी लिख देता हूं सेल की
डेफिनेशन
डी कमांड
यू
टाइप
टाइप इन योर
टर्मिनल
टर्मिनल और
आशीष
जैन
ऑन तू डी
ओपनिंग सिस्टम
और युवा
और यू और
युटुब
इशू कमांड्स
तू कंप्यूटर
व्हाट इसे काम क्या कलर चेंज
अगेन
और क्या है की देखो इसमें क्या है की
स्पेशलिटी क्या है पहले बात तो क्या है
इसका मतलब क्या है बोनस जो ऑर्डर वर्जन था
उसमें जो थोड़ी बहुत प्रॉब्लम थी जो
अपडेशन अपडेट करना चाहता हूं अपग्रेड कर
चुके हैं इसमें एडवांस है ऊपर से फास्ट भी
है और आजकल तो सबका फेवरेट हो गया है ये
बेस्ट सेल इसलिए हम क्या है
अब बात करते हैं हम
स्क्रिप्ट होता क्या है
आप लोगों को
बात करते हैं
अकेले में इसको क्या कर रहा हूं जूम कर
देता हूं
व्हाट इस स्क्रिप्ट
क्या होता है देखो
कमांड्स होती है जिसके अंदर सीरीज ऑफ
कमांड
जिसके अंदर कमांड होती है अब सेल क्या
करता है की जो स्क्रिप्ट है जिसको हम फाइल
बोलते हैं इसको रीड करता है और इसके अंदर
जो सीरीज ऑफ कमांड्स हमने क्या किया मेंशन
की हुई है राइट की हुई है
उनको क्या करता है वन बाय वन एग्जीक्यूट
करता है तो बेसिकली अगर मैं बोलूं
स्क्रिप्ट या सेल्स बेस्ट गिफ्ट क्या होता
है बेसिकली वो क्या है बेसिकली
कमांड्स
कंटेनिंग कमांड्स पर डी बेस्ट डेफिनेशन
करते हैं देखो
वीक में एक बार किसी भी एक दिन उसका टाइम
डिसाइड किया गया है
उसे दिन उसको रन करना ही करना है
और आप क्या कर रहे हो वहां पर एडमिन
ड्यूटी कर रहे हैं
आपके सामने यहां पर तीन सवाल खड़े हो जाते
हैं तो सबसे पहले
सबसे पहले सवाल क्या आया
हो मैच
इसे आईटी
एवरी वीक
एवरी वीक पर यू
सबसे पहले सवाल
[संगीत]
में
एक एडिशनल टास्क के एड हो गया की मुझे इस
दिन की इन 20 कमांड्स को पहले तो याद रखना
है और उसके बाद इनको इस दिन परफॉर्म करना
ही करना है एडरवाइज प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट हो
शक्ति है क्योंकि आपके बस ने बोला है
दूसरा जो की आपके साथ प्रॉब्लम ए शक्ति है
दूसरी प्रॉब्लम क्या होगा की देखो व्हाट
हैपन
व्हाट हैपन आईएफ
समथिंग
गज
रंग और
यू बैक
समथिंग
समथिंग भाई
टाइपिंग
इनकरेक्टली
बेसिकली मतलब मेरा खाने का मतलब क्या है
की इधर दूसरा प्रॉब्लम क्या है की अगर कुछ
गलत हो गया हो सकता है
मतलब की कमांड तो चलानी थी कुछ और चला कुछ
दिया
प्रॉब्लम क्या है की व्हाट हैपन क्या होगा
व्हाट हैपन आईएफ
यू फॉरगेट
तू डू
आईटी वन वीक
में इन 20 कमांड्स को क्या करना है
एक स्पेसिफिक डेट और एक स्पेसिफिक टाइम पर
उसको शेड्यूल कर देते हो
अब जब शेड्यूल कर देते तो क्या होता है की
उसके लिए जिसको अगर आप लोगों ने सुना होगा
क्रोम जॉब्स होती हैं आपकी सिस्टम में वो
क्या कर देती है ऑटोमेटेकली इस स्क्रिप्ट
को उसे दिन और उसे तारीख को उसे टाइम पर
ऑटोमेटेकली रन कर देती है जहां पर आपको 20
कमांड याद करने की जरूर नहीं है जहां पर
आपके साथ टाइप हो एरर नहीं हो शक्ति हां
पर आपसे गलती नहीं हो शक्ति और ऊपर से
आपको याद भी नहीं करना तो इसने क्या कर
दिया आपके काम को ऑटोमेटिक कर दिया ऊपर से
केवल जो आप जो अपना काम कर रहे थे वो करते
हुए बताइए मतलब ये काम हो ही जाएगा
क्योंकि इंपॉर्टेंट टास्क था तो बेसिकली
मैं क्या बोल सकता हूं की जो मेरा
जो मेरा यह स्क्रिप्ट है उसका बेसिक परपज
इसने क्या-क्या किया
आपकी लिबर्टी को बीच में इंक्रीज कर दिया
तो इन्हीं तीन कर कर्म से क्या है
रिलायबिलिटी की स्पेलिंग
को उसे करते हैं आई हो की एक बार मुझे ये
बता दीजिए की अभी तक जो मैं बता रहा हूं
आप लोगों को समझ में ए रहा है या नहीं ए
रहा प्लीज जल्दी से बता दीजिए
चलो काम करते हैं आगे बढ़ते हैं
अब मैं आपको समझता हूं स्ट्रक्चर अपने
बेस्ट गिफ्ट की जो स्ट्रक्चर है उसके बड़े
में बात करने वाली भी स्ट्रक्चर कैसी होती
है देखो थोड़ा थ्योरी प्लस प्रैक्टिकल
राहत है डोंट वारी इस बात की चिंता मत
कीजिए की आपको थ्योरी नहीं मिलेगी ओ
प्रैक्टिकल नहीं मिलेगा प्रैक्टिकल भी
होगा लेकिन जो मैं करवा रहा हूं वो इस
लेवल का है भले ही इस ग्रुप में किसी को
भी स्क्रिप्टिंग आई हो दर्जन मटर बट इस
बात की कोई हर इस बात की गारंटी है की
उसको भी वो चीज पता नहीं होगी जो हम आपको
बताने जहां रहा ओके जो मैं आपको बताने जा
रहा हूं तो अब बात करते हैं कंटिन्यू करते
हैं अपने टॉपिक को हम कंटिन्यू लेक चलते
हैं
जो स्ट्रक्चर ऑफ बिस्कुट स्ट्रक्चर
के बड़े में बात करना तो बहुत ही ज्यादा
जरूरी है यह है 1 मिनट
ओके
एस
कप स्ट्रक्चर
मिडिल ओके
बिगनिंग मिडिल और
क्या करते हो बेस्ट गिफ्ट करते हो
बेंगलें किसको बोलते हैं
जो बेस्ट है आपको
याद
व्हाट
टाइप ऑफ इंटरप्रेटर व्हाट टाइप ऑफ
इंटरप्रेटर
करने
वाले हैं ठीक है
ट्रांसलेट
वन स्टेटमेंट
[संगीत]
ओके आपको दिखा देता हूं
पर एग्जांपल
इन दोनों को आपस में
कम्युनिकेट करना है परसों ए को परसों बी
से कम्युनिकेट करना है तो वह कैसे
कम्युनिकेट करेंगे तो आपको पता है अगर इन
दोनों को आपस में कम्युनिकेट करना है तो
इनको एक क्या चाहिए होगा बीच में एक
ट्रांसलेटर चाहिए होगा भैया बीच में क्या
चाहिए होगा ट्रांसलेटर
रखना हूं
[संगीत]
ट्रांसलेटर
ट्रांसलेटर चाहिए मैंने जिसको बोला अब
ट्रांसलेटर क्या करेगा ट्रांसलेटर क्या
करेगा इन दोनों के बीच में कम्युनिकेशन का
काम करेगा तो अब ट्रांसलेटर के पास जो है
उसके पास दो ऑप्शंस हैं इसके पास दो
ऑप्शंस हैं पहले ऑप्शन क्या है
उसको समझे उसके बाद क्या करें परसों बी को
ट्रांसलेट करें पहले खुद से समझे उसका
मतलब समझे उसके बाद परसों देखो ट्रांसलेट
करें पहले तो ऑप्शन है ये दूसरा ऑप्शन
क्या है की वह क्या करेगा
वन शब्द बोला दो शब्द बोले एक साथ या तीन
शब्द एक साथ बोले या एक लाइन पुरी
स्टेटमेंट बोला उसको साथ के साथ परसों दे
दो ट्रांसलेट करते मतलब स्टेटमेंट बाय
स्टेटमेंट
उसको क्या बोल सकते हैं इंटरप्रेटर
इंटरप्रेटर वह क्या करता है एक बार में एक
स्टेटमेंट लगा उसको मशीन कोड में कन्वर्ट
करें उसके बाद नेक्स्ट स्टेटमेंट लगा उसको
मशीन कोड में कन्वर्ट करेगा फिर वन स्टेट
नेक्स्ट स्टेटमेंट फिर मशीन
की जो एग्जांपल मैंने लिया आपको अच्छे से
समझ में आएगा की ट्रांसलेटर एक्चुअल
इंटरप्रेटर होता क्या है वो बेसिकली
ट्रांसलेट करता है वन स्टेटमेंट आते ए
टाइम इन मशीन कोड ये होता है ट्रांसलेटर
तो अभी फिर से हम अपने टॉपिक पे ए जाते
हैं ये रहा हमारा टॉपिक क्या था की जो
सीमेंट पार्ट है वो आपके सेल को बताता है
की इस फाइल को रीड करने के लिए किस टाइप
का ट्रांसलेटर उसे करने वाले हो अब आपने
देखा होगा जब भी आप क्या करते हो इस तरीके
से कमांड लिखने हो ताकि मैं आपको नीचे
दिखता हूं इधर हो गया
इसके तुरंत बाद
इसके तुरंत बाद आप क्या करते हैं देखो
इंटरप्रेटर का फूल पाठ जिसका आप उसे करोगे
इस फाइल को रीड करने के लिए इसके बाद क्या
करते हो आप फूल पाठ ऑफ डी इंटरप्रेटर
जिसका उसे करें हम क्या लिखने हैं
मैं प्रैक्टिकल करके दिखाऊं डोंट वारी
यहां पे मैंने क्या कर दिया स्लैश बिन
स्लैश मैं यहां पे मेंशन कर रहा हूं इसका
मतलब क्या है देखो इसको मैंने क्या साइज
बड़ा देता हूं थोड़ा ये रहा स्लैश में और
ये आपको अगर अलर्ट करके दिखता हूं एक बार
ये रहा
आपको इसको मैं क्या कर देता हूं एक बार
हाईलाइट भी कर देता हूं इट्स ओके
तुरंत बाद इमीडीएटली हम क्या करते हैं वो
फूल पाठ मैनेजमेंट करते हैं जो इंटरप्रेटर
का
रेडी करेगा तो यहां पर हमने
जहां पर बेस्ट सेल क्या है इंस्टॉल है
हमारी मशीन में तो आपको पता है हमारी मशीन
में साड़ी बाइनरी फाइल्स डायरेक्टर के
अंदर होती है भिन्न के अंदर बेस्ट नाम का
जो है जो सेल है वो वहां पर अवेलेबल है तो
इसलिए हमने ये पाठ यहां पर मेंशन कर दिया
स्टेटमेंट स्टार्ट होती है आपके मशीन में
स्टार्ट होती है पर एग्जांपल मैं आपको एक
बार प्रैक्टिकल करके दिखता हूं जैसे ये
रहा
इधर अब यह मेरा अभी जो मैं मशीन उसे कर
रहा हूं आपके सामने यह मशीन में क्या कर
रहा हूं कल उबंटू की नहीं मैं रेड है की
मशीन उसे कर रहा हूं क्योंकि मेरी उबंटू
मशीन में कुछ उसकी ओपन तू या काली ने मशीन
में प्रॉब्लम चल रहा है इसलिए किसी भी
मशीन पे स्क्रिप्टिंग करो कोई सुन नहीं से
काम करेगी अभी मैं क्या करता हूं सबसे
पहले मैं करता हूं अभी एम के दी आई या एक
एमके डॉ एक डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट कर लेट हूं
बेस्ट बेस्ट
प्रोजेक्ट के नाम से प्रोजेक्ट के नाम से
डायरेक्टली क्रिएट डायरेक्टली क्रिएट कर
लिया अब मैं करता हूं बेस्ट प्रोजेक्ट के
अंदर जाता हूं बेस्ट प्रोजेक्ट के अंदर
बेस्ट प्रोजेक्ट
करता हूं कौन सी फाइल क्रिएट करता हूं की
हेल्प से करता है अवर
और स्क्रिप्ट स्क्रिप्ट अभी आप चाहे तो सब
उसे कर सकते हो एडरवाइज आप विदाउट सब आप
अपनी फाइल को क्रिएट कर सकते हो मैंने
क्या
अभी मैंने क्या बताया था सबसे पहले जो
लाइन स्टार्ट होती है आपकी बेस्ट गिफ्ट
में सबसे पहले जो लाइन होती है वो होती है
सी बैंक लाइन शिबैंक लाइंस सबसे पहले उससे
पहले कोई भी ब्लैक लाइन नहीं हो शक्ति और
ना ही उससे पहले कोई
कमेंट कुछ भी नहीं हो सकता तो हम सबसे
पहले उसे करेंगे जो मैंने आपको बताया और
ये रहा
इसको हम बोलते हैं मैंने उसके बाद क्या
बताया था आपको उसके तुरंत बाद हम उसे करते
हैं किसको इंटरप्रेटर को और फूल पाठ
मैनेजमेंट करेंगे जो इंटरप्रेटर हम उसे
करने वाले हैं इस फाइल को रीड करने के लिए
इंटरप्रेटर आई होप सबको
इंटरप्रेटर है जो फर्स्ट लाइन में उसे कर
रहा हूं मैं अगर मैं इसको पूरा का पूरा
उसे ही ना करूं
तो क्या होगा क्या प्रॉब्लम हो शक्ति है
इसकी वजह
से तो देखो
अगर आप सीमेंट लाइन उसे नहीं करें या
इंटरप्रेटर वाली फूल लाइन उसे नहीं कर रहे
तो इसके अंदर जो भी कमांड है अब जो भी कोड
लिखोगे वह एग्जीक्यूट करेगा ही बट कहां
एग्जीक्यूट करेगा वो आपके करंट सेल में
अब करंट सेल कौन सा है पर एग्जांपल
मैं क्या करता हूं एस्केप मोड हो जाता हूं
इस कंपनी कंट्रोल एक्स करते हैं मेरा
[संगीत]
सेल ठीक है
प्रॉब्लम हो शक्ति हो सकता है
की वो बेस्ट स्पेसिफिक कुछ आइटम्स हो जो
विश में ही अच्छे तरह से अपना और कुछ शो
करें लेकिन आपने वहां पर इंटरनेट
सेल कौन सा उसे कर रही हो
कस
कर रही हो अब उसकी वजह से देखो और तो
एग्जीक्यूट करेंगे बट उसकी वजह से हो सकता
है की कुछ प्रॉब्लम्स आपको देखने को मिले
या जैसा आउटपुट ना आए दूसरा
बैंक लाइन को या इंटरप्रेटर को उसे करना
जो फर्स्ट लाइन की मैं बात कर रहा हूं कौन
सी जो फर्स्ट लाइन है ये रही इस फर्स्ट
लाइन की जो मैं बात कर रहा हूं इसका उसे
करना इंपॉर्टेंट इसलिए भी है अगर आप किसी
टीम के साथ काम कर रहे हो और वहां पर क्या
कर रहे हो
आप कोई स्क्रिप्ट लिख रहे हो
तो वहां पर आपको आइडिया ही नहीं है की जो
आपके दोस्त हैं जो आपके टीम मेंबर्स हैं
वह कौन सा सेल उसे करने वाले हैं जब इस
स्क्रिप्ट को उसे करेंगे क्योंकि देखो
आपने कोड अपनी मेहनत से लिखा अच्छे से
लिखा और
टेस्ट करके लिखा है अब आपको नहीं पता की
आपके जो टीम मेंबर्स हैं वो कौन सा करंट
सालों उसे करने वाले हैं जब इस आपके
स्क्रिप्ट को उसे करेंगे अब पता चला की
आपने इंटरप्रेटर उसे किया नहीं इसी बैंक
लाइन आपने उसे की नहीं और उन्होंने सिस
सेल्फी उसे कर लिया तो आपने इतनी मेहनत की
आज से 10 दिन किसी प्रोजेक्ट पर लगाया और
उसने उसे क्या बोला की नोट सक्सेसफुल जैसा
आउटपुट चीता वैसा आउटपुट नहीं ए रहा आप
इसको देखिए इसमें बॉक्स है बट अब गलती
आपने क्या की थी की आपने फ्रंटलाइन जो है
इसे बैंक पार्ट वाले जो लाइन है उसको उसे
ही नहीं की जो जिसको हम बोलते हैं बिगनिंग
ऑफ डी लाइन यही है वह बिगनिंग ऑफ डी
बिगनिंग और पार्ट है इसी को हम बिगनिंग कर
पार्ट बोलते हैं
तो फिर
उसकी वजह से आप क्या हुआ की आपका प्रॉब्लम
बाढ़ गई तो इसलिए मैं आपको बताया की यह
इंपॉर्टेंट है
अब आप बोलोगे सर कैसे पता चला की सिस्टम
कोई भी यह इससे एग्जीक्यूट कर रहा है तो
देखो सीधी सी बातें कंट्रोल एक्स किया
मैंने अब मैं मुझे नहीं पता ये कौन सी
फाइल तो आपको पता है की लिस्ट में कमांड
होती है फाइल उसके बाद आप लिखिए
किस टाइप के फाइल है मतलब बेस्ट है अब
मैंने क्या किया इंटरप्रेटर चेंज कर दिया
पर एग्जांपल मैंने इंटर फिल्टर यहां पर
क्या कर दिया अब इंटरनेट में मैंने लिखा
की आपको फ्लैश बिन की जगह मैंने क्या लिखा
अभी मैंने यहां पे लिख दिया प्लस यू एस आर
एस आपको लिखा मैंने बिन और मैंने यहां पर
पाइथन का इंटरप्रेटर कर दिया
उसके बाद दिया कर दिया कंट्रोल एक्स किया
यस किया यस अब मैं इसके बाद फिर से फाइल
करता हूं फाइल कमांड चलता हूं उसके बाद
अवर स्क्रिप्ट
एसएससी ये देखो एक्सटेंशन है आईटी इंटर
किया अब इसने क्या बताया
किसने बताया की यह पाइथन की स्क्रिप्ट है
इसमें क्या बताया
जो आपने सी बैंक लाइन के साथ जो एंटरटेन
किया इस से पता चला की भैया मुझे इस फाइल
को रीड करने के लिए इस इंटरप्रेटर का उसे
करना है तो आई होप आपको समझ में ए गया
होगा की कैसे फर्स्ट लाइन आपको डिफाइन
करनी है जब भी आप अपने बेस्ट स्क्रिप्ट
लिखोगे तो आज मैं स्ट्रक्चर बता रहा हूं
तो ये जो है मैंने बताया आपको
फिर से फिर से बात कर रहा हूं
[संगीत]
तो अभी मैं फिर से क्या करता हूं इसको
देता हूं
[संगीत]
जिसकी मैं बात कर रहा हूं बिगनिंग और
कंपोनेंट ये रहा इसके बाद करता हूं तो अगर
मैं यहां पर एक काम करता हूं ये रहा इसको
मैं बोलूंगा एक मिनट
चलो यार इसको हम बोल सकते हैं
इसको हम क्या करेंगे
और कंपोनेंट
कंपोनेंट
ठीक है
[संगीत]
दिस इसे मी फर्स्ट स्किप
लाइन भी हो शक्ति हैं और सिंगल लाइन भी हो
शक्ति है 1000500
कितनी भी लाइन हो शक्ति है इसको हम क्या
बोल सकते हैं मिडिल कर कंपोनेंट इसको क्या
बोलेंगे हमीदल कोड कंपोनेंट तो अभी यहां
पर हम अगर आपको डायग्राम के साथ आगे मिडिल
कंपोनेंट का पार्ट लेकर दिखाओ तो यहां पे
बोलूंगा मैं ये रहा यहां पर ए जाएगा मेरा
कोई कंपोनेंट में क्या आएगा ये रहा मैं
इधर कर रहा हूं लो साइज थोड़ा छोटा कर
देते इसका मिडिल करो मैंने क्या लिखा है
उसके बाद ये
दिस इसे मी
फर्स्ट स्टेप
ये मेरा क्या है अगर मैं इसको
[संगीत]
मिडिल कार्ड कंपोनेंट
मिडिल कर कंपनी
उसे करना है उसके बाद मैंने क्या कर दिया
मिडिल कर कॉम्पोनेंट्स में वो कमांड वो
कोड लिखा जो मैं एक्चुअल में एग्जीक्यूट
करवाना चाहता हूं वो काम या वो प्रोग्राम
जो आपने ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम से या ऑटोमेशन जो
करवाना चाहता हूं जो टास्क को फोन करवाना
चाहता हूं यहां पर वो एक्चुअल में यहां पर
मैच नहीं करते हैं तो ये है मिडिल कर
कंपोनेंट आता है अब और कर कंपोनेंट में
क्या आता है अगर और फोर कंपोनेंट के बाद
कंट्रोल सी इधर कंट्रोल भी ये रहा और कॉल
कंप्लेंट के बात करूं तो यहां पर आएगा और
कर कंपोनेंट में आपका
यहां पर आएगा आपका एग्जिट स्टेटस
इसका कौन सा कंपोनेंट है
और कंपोनेंट
इस तरीके से आपका कोड लिखा जाएगा
है तो अभी जो एग्जिट स्टेटस कोड होता है
वह होता है जीरो से 255
कोड होता है वह जीरो से 255 होता है अगर
जब भी आपकी कमांड या कोई भी आपकी गिफ्ट है
जब वो सक्सेसफुली एग्जीक्यूट हो जाति है
तो उसका जो स्टेटस फोड़ होता है वो जीरो
होता है अगर आपका स्टेटस को नॉन जीरो आता
है तो वह तब आता है जब आपकी कोई भी कमांड
या कोई भी स्क्रिप्ट अनसक्सेसफुल होती है
फेल हो जाति है तो उसका एक्जिस्ट स्टेटस
पर
वन से लेकर 250 के बीच में कुछ भी हो सकता
है अभी देखो
हमने तो कहानी देखने को मिलता नहीं है
की जरूरी नहीं है की आप एग्जिट स्टेटस
एसेसरी की आपको एग्जिट स्टेटस पर मेंशन
करना ही करना है
तो एक्जिस्ट स्टेटस कोड मेंशन ही क्यों
करें देखो क्या होता है आपके लिए एक जरूरी
नहीं है लेकिन सेल क्या करते हैं इसको टेक
केयर करता है तेल क्या करता है की आपकी जो
लास्ट कमांड है मेरी यहां पर लास्ट कमांड
कौन सी है तो इसका जो एग्जिट स्टेटस कोड
होगा चाहे वो जीरो हो या वन से लेकर 255
के बीच में इसका जो भी एडजेस्ट्रेटर्स कोड
है उसको क्या होगा लास्ट एग्जिट स्टेटस
कोड मां के
उसको क्या करेगा एग्जिट स्टेटस कोड मां
लगा फाइनल एग्जिट स्टेटस पर तो इसका मतलब
क्या करता है की मैं मुझे खुद से डिफाइन
करने की जरूर नहीं होती है ऑटोमेटेकली इस
लाइन जो लास्ट लाइन का जो एग्जिट स्टेटस
पर है उसको ही अपना फाइनल एग्जिट स्टेटस
कोड को मानता है इस स्क्रिप्ट का और उसके
बेसिस पे स्किप का आपको देता है अगर ये
फेल हुई तो उसके फेल होगी अगर ये पास होगी
तो उसकी पास होगी तो ये थी आपकी स्ट्रक्चर
ऑफ डी स्क्रिप्ट अब मैं इसको करता हूं
कंट्रोल
एक्स कर देता हूं यस भैया यस कर दिया अब
मेरी क्या है मैंने
सबको समझ में ए रहा होगा मुझे ये बताइए
आपको समझ में आया होगा अगर इसमें किसी को
ऐसे लगता है की ये सब नहीं समझ में आपने
क्या बता दिया एक बार मैं इसको क्या करता
हूं इसको
इमेज स्ट्रक्चर
[संगीत]
अब बात करते हैं
उसके बाद क्या होता है
[संगीत]
वह बता दीजिए कौन सी सीरीज में है
मजाक क्या कर सकते हो उसको देख सकते हो तो
आपको कौन सी परमीशंस पर सेट करनी चाहिए तो
परमिशन सेट में कैसे करूंगा देखो क्या
होता है की
मैं ल करके दिखता हूं आपको तो अभी तक इसके
ऊपर जो ये फाइल है ना
इसके ऊपर हमने एग्जीक्यूट परमिशन सेट नहीं
किया तो किसी भी स्किप को एग्जीक्यूट करने
के लिए हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा उसको
एग्जीक्यूट परमिशन मेंशन करने की तो उसके
लिए सी हा मोड में आइंस्टीन करूंगा प्लस
एक्स एग्जीक्यूट उसके बाद स्किप का नाम
अवर नोट असेट्स अब मैं एनल करता हूं तो
आपको देखने को मिलोगे ऐसे एग्जिट परमिशन
दे दी और skip.s और क्या करूंगा मैं इसको
एक्सक्यूट करवाने के लिए मुझे क्या करूंगा
ये डॉट उसके बाद ये उसके बाद मैं अपनी
स्क्रिप्ट का नाम अवर फर्स्ट स्क्रिप्ट
इंटर किया तो इसने क्या का दिया दिस इसे
मी फर्स्ट गिफ्ट आपको आउटपुट आपको देखने
को मिलता है तब आप लोग बोलो सर ये क्यों
किया ये क्यों किया
जाता हूं जब मैंने ये मेंशन किया है इधर ए
क्या होता है देखो अभी आपके सामने ही समझा
दूंगा इसको देखो
इसका मतलब क्या है
आप सबको पता है अगर नहीं पता होगा की मैं
आपको बता देता हूं यह रहा
है
आपको
करंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी प्रेजेंट करता है
आपका करंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी को
रिप्रेजेंट करता है उसके बाद जो फॉरवर्ड
स्लाइस है ये रहा ये जो फॉरवर्ड स्लाइस है
ये भी प्रेजेंट करता है आपका
डायरेक्टरी सेपरेटर वैसे तो अगर सिंगल आप
इसको ऐसे ही उसे करोगे ये है अगर मैं
सिंगल उसे करता हूं तो ये क्या है आपका
रूट डायरेक्टली याद आई है अगर मैं इसको
क्या करता हूं ऐसे उसे करता हूं पर
एग्जांपल पीडी करता हूं मैं ये क्या ए रहा
है
अब अगर मैं क्या करता हूं सीडी नोट करता
हूं देखो क्या मेरी डायरेक्टर चेंज हुई
इसका मतलब क्या है करंट वर्किंग
डायरेक्टरी यह एक सेपरेटर काम कर रहा है
और ये है उसका फाइल का नाम अगर आप ऐसे
लिखना चाहे तो तुम भी काम करेगी
इसका मतलब क्या है इसका मतलब है देखो
भैया इसका मतलब है आपने स्टार्टिंग में
इसको करंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी क्या है
मेरी रूट है उसके बाद मेरा क्या है
रूट बेस्ट प्रोजेक्टर
सेपरेट कर दिया उसके बाद अवास्क्रिप्ट
इसका मतलब ये है ऐसे एग्जीक्यूट कर पी तो
मैंने क्या कर दिया और एकजुट कैसे कर पे
क्योंकि मैंने इसको एग्जीक्यूट परमिशन दी
थी कौन सी परमिशन दी थी एग्जिट पाल
करके दिखता हूं ये रहा मेरा एग्जीक्यूट
परमिशन अब आपको एक चीज बताऊं जब भी आप
स्क्रिप्ट के साथ काम कर रहे होते हैं तो
आपको ऐसे परमिशन नहीं देनी चाहिए आपको
बेसिकली क मोड करना है द मोड उसके बाद
744 परमिशन ही देनी चाहिए आपको किसी भी
स्क्रिप्ट को किसी भी स्क्रिप्ट को 744
परमिशन ही देनी चाहिए इसके अलावा यही
परमिशन देनी चाहिए आपको ओन्ली जो इसका ओनर
है इस को ही फूल परमिशन देनी चाहिए
एडरवाइज बाकी सब को रीड परमिशन ही हनी
चाहिए 744 क्या होता है
आपको यही परमिशन देनी चाहिए परमिशन का
स्पेशली ध्यान रखना चाहिए एडरवाइज क्या है
की अगर कोई भी एग्जीक्यूट कर पाएगा और ओके
और कोई किसी और करने का हक नहीं होना
चाहिए
ओके तो आप किसी बिस्कुट पर देने हैं तो
आपको 744 परमिशन ही मेंशन करनी चाहिए तो
यह थी बात वो इंटरेस्टिंग फैक्ट और मिशन
की उसके बाद मैंने बताया की आप जब
स्क्रिप्ट को कैसे एग्जीक्यूट करवा सकते
हो उसके बाद मैंने बताया की स्ट्रक्चर्स
कैसी होती है आपकी स्किप की यह सब मैंने
बताया आपको तो आज का टॉपिक यही था इतना ही
हम करेंगे आई होप की किसी को मैंने बोर्ड
नहीं किया होगा और शायद सबको समझ में आया
होगा एक बार चाट में आपके पास 2 मिनट का
समय है की सबको समझ में आया नहीं आया मैं
आपको बता देता हूं आज मैंने क्या-क्या
बताया वैसे एक बार यह रहा स्टार्टिंग से
बताता हूं सबसे पहले मैंने क्या बताया
सबसे पहले मैंने बताया की
तेल क्या होता है उसके बाद मैंने बताया की
सेल का परपज क्या है उसके बाद मैंने बताया
की बेस्ट क्या होता है
उसके बाद मैंने बताया की स्क्रिप्ट क्या
होता है उसके हम क्यों उसे करते हैं उसके
बाद मैंने बताया
जिसको हम स्क्रिप्ट करने वाले हैं उसकी
स्ट्रक्चर क्या होती है उसकी तीन कोड
कंपोनेंट होता है बिगनिंग मिडिल और
बिगनिंग कंपोनेंट कौन सा होता है
क्यों हम उसको उसे करते हैं
इंटरप्रेटर क्या होता है क्यों इंटरप्रेटर
काम उसे करते हैं
उसके बाद मैंने बताया की मिडिल कर
कंपोनेंट कौन सा होता है
एग्जिट स्टेटस
जल्दी से मुझे बता दीजिए
अगर किसी को आज के टॉपिक से रिलेटेड कोई
भी क्वेश्चन अगर पूछना है तो वह पूछ सकता
है अभी से 2 मिनट आप लोग
के हिसाब से मैंने इसको क्या किया है आपको
डिलीवरी किया है
मैं आपको पहले बताता हूं की निक क्लास में
क्या होने वाला है आपको पहले ही देता हूं
नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम एक-एक स्क्रिप्ट
क्रिएट करके दिखाएंगे आपको गिफ्ट क्रिएट
करके दिखाऊंगा उसके बाद फरदर हम स्टार्ट
करेंगे अपने कुछ फोटो फिक्स लेकिन पहले हम
आपको एक स्क्रिप्ट करके दिखाऊंगा की एक
अच्छी एक खूबसूरत
प्रॉब्लम क्योंकि काफी टाइम बाद पढ़ा रहा
हूं तो हो सकता है की थोड़ा सा तरीका बादल
गया हो गया थोड़ा सा कुछ हो गया हो डोंट
वारी एक गिव मी मुझे गिव मी सम तू तू थ्री
डेज तू तू थ्री क्लासेस आई बिल काम बैक तू
मी
बैक पोजीशन
तो कमेंट जरूर कीजिएगा
तो कंडीशन आपको पता है अगर आपको नया सेशन
शेड्यूल करवाना है तो वन के उसे 4200
लाइक्स कमेंट्स होने चाहिए हमारी वीडियो
के ऊपर तभी नेक्स्ट सेशन शेड्यूल होगा
नेक्स्ट क्लास आपकी होगी बेस्ट स्क्रिप्ट
के ऊपर और डोंट वारी ये मत सोचिए कोर्स एक
दिन में खत्म हो जाएगा नो 1 दिन में नहीं
है तो काम से काम आपको बता रहा हूं उसकी
25 + वीडियो आपकी आने वाली है और इतनी
शॉर्ट ड्यूरेशन वाली वीडियो आपको क्या पता
30 वीडियो भी हो जाए ओके बट कस इतना डिटेल
दो होगा एवं अगर आप किसी के पैसे दे के भी
आप पढ़ के आए हो ऐसा कोर्स कोई नहीं पढ़ा
सकता जैसे हम पढ़ना वाला हूं जी तरीके से
मैं पढ़ना वाला अगर कोई भी पढ़ा देता हूं
मैं कोर्स युटुब से हटा दूंगा अगर एक भी
बांदा बोल देंगे सर क्या अपना कोर्स
बेगाना पड़ाया और पैसे वाले अच्छे पढ़ा
देते अगर मैं ऐसे कोई अच्छा कोर्स पढ़ा
देगा ना युटुब से मैं पुरी वीडियो करवा
दूंगा